Kalin Robertson lovely to see and I want
to stop with a very straightforward
question how would you describe yourself
what do you see as your your job your
rule I would say I'm like an alternative
producer so covering the stories that a
lot of traditional median establishment
media don't want to talk about or to
worry to talk about sort of covering the
other side of a lot of the conversations
that aren't being discussed even in day
to day life I'm bringing production
value to that as well and legitimizing
those arguments so they're not like
fringe sort of things on there on the
corners of the internet and bringing the
bringing up to the mainstream you had
quite an interesting journey to get to
that position though I mean you started
off as something of a youtube
personality didn't you well I wouldn't
say I started off as that I say that I
had it as a hobby when I was younger
when I was studying I had the YouTube
channel and thought it'd be fun to throw
crazy stuff out all over the internet
but it wasn't like a career I didn't
think it would be taken very seriously
or anything like would would happen with
it it was just fun sort of a friends
living in like a boring town in the
north of England as well like it's not
much going on so Facebook is exciting
they're you know doing that kind of
stuff
but no like my career was always in
marketing and politics and well sort of
PR and things like that at University
and and after I graduated here my
partner was at the BBC and I was working
in marketing and PR firms and that's
where everything was really really
focused and that's obviously how I
transitioned from from sort of
traditional establishment sectors into
what we're doing now sort of taking all
the textbook stuff and applying it to
kind of more sort of Fringe alternative
subjects which is interesting but there
was there was a film wasn't that that
you wanted to make when you are when you
were in further education about tell us
a little bit about that one yeah well I
made a like I think was like a nine
minute film just about a it wasn't an
John charity but there was like a bunch
of Muslim extremists who were walking up
and down Whitechapel and I was just
interviewing a few of them not that they
would really want to talk very much but
like going up to their cameras and then
I showed it to one of my lecturers and
they were like oh this is this is
interesting but we're not gonna put it
in the screening of the official like of
the official screening of all the short
films at the end of the year I was like
oh that's really strange and do anything
much of it but then when I started
googling about universities not like
deep platforming things or maybe not
showing all different ideas I mean what
was what was the rationale giving to you
right okay this is interesting
what but you don't walk when I'm gonna
have it in the end of year they said I
remember them using the word
inflammatory that it could be perceived
as inflammatory I think they it wasn't
from like a super insidious way I think
they were just trying to be polite to a
lot of the other students and they
didn't want to upset a lot of different
people and bring that kind of argument
into the classroom so I wasn't really
that bothered about it at the time until
I started researching that other
universities were doing things like that
but yeah that was that was sort of the
first time I recognized that that was
going on I mean is it fair for me to
then join the dots between that instant
that film and then you're later what was
with Tommy Robinson formerly of the EDL
yeah well this is why I say that the
left crater Tommy like the left created
this situation as well like if you would
only show something maybe we have some
difficult conversations and actually not
silence freedom of speech or not silence
content then people might not start
questioning this tumor people might not
start dedicating their lives to it or
getting involved in activism to try and
fight it like that wouldn't that
wouldn't be the case because there
wouldn't be there wouldn't be a silence
around it they wouldn't be these issues
so yeah that was definitely the like a
major part in the transition to at least
like he gave Tommy Robinson credibility
to me when I first heard that because
before I had heard of him and I was like
oh my god the big scary racist cd-r guy
and then after after what happened to me
and after researching you know I was
like hmm maybe there's something else
going on so you would you wouldn't use
the word racist to describe Tommy wasn't
no like I was described a lot of his
supporters and a lot of people around
him as racist
they hate Muslims because they're
Bradley they have no idea about ideology
or politics in any way but as a person I
would say he's not racist
isn't there a guilt by association
though mm I don't think so I think it's
inevitable if you keep saying something
over and over again and you discover
that lots of racists like it you know
it's at the very least arguable that
you're approaching something racist
yourself isn't it yeah I think he should
do more to disavow it I mean he's very
he's very vocal about anti-racist stuff
he hates hates racism and he talks about
that in his videos but he should be more
vocal about it and showing that done
it's like the Labour Party only 70
semitism thing you know there's there's
there's lots of lots of stuff like that
going on with him within an organization
but it doesn't mean Jeremy Corbyn
specifically is like a hardcore
anti-semite but there are supporters who
are like that in the same movement but
like Tommy he should do more to disavow
it I mean it clearly you have moved on
from your relationship with Tommy
Robbins and you
working with others not at the same time
that there was a moment in the aftermath
of the of that terrorist attack that
took place on London Bridge where both
you and Tommy were down there and you
recorded as we say in the tree that a
bit of a piece to camera and I just want
to replay it to you for a second here
we've been here for about 20 minutes now
and we don't have any update on
specifically what's happened but what we
do know based on all the reports is that
a car has plowed through Westminster
Bridge and crashed into the houses of
parliament gun shots have been fired
within the gates and three people have
been confirmed dead if you import a
culture you get a culture this is the
culture of violence destruction and
terrorism they want war they will death
they want destruction and we keep on
pandering like you like you just come
out to me saying he's got nothing to do
with Islam
he's got everything to do with Islam the
blood is on the hands of people like you
and the left who have allowed these
people to come into our country and
caused chaos I mean I'm being I'm being
slightly unfair to describe your view
the way that you were looking when we
were playing that clip I mean you were
cringing when you watch some crime what
do you find cringe-worthy about it
specifically and it's just not correct
like it's it's what what we were talking
about isn't correct
we're basically throwing a huge group of
people into the same basket and they're
saying that they're at war with us when
it's a tiny tiny tiny number and we
didn't specify that and I mean it just
it's just losing control it's not
helping it's not anything to you
argument I think it's just in flaming
tensions and it's just a bit
embarrassing but I mean you put your
kicked your giggling there but the
sentiment contained from both your cell
phone and from Tommy Robinson was that
Islam led to events on London Bridge
sure what's your view of that no I think
there are there are parts of Islam that
are still super violent like lots of
light lots of literature it's it's
worrying that so many people follow that
but it's not I mean it would be silly to
say that every single person who reads a
Quran every single Muslim is I you know
anti infidel extremist like it like the
numbers just don't add up otherwise the
world would be brought chaos with 1.2
billion Muslims are
many people around the world it's easy
to say things like that like the things
I said on that show on the internet
because there aren't really any
real-life repercussions to me and it
gets a lot of views that video got more
views than pretty much like Sky News and
BBC combined on the internet like it was
huge it was fired a lot of people fell
that yeah but it was wrong yeah but well
there that doesn't mean that it didn't
go viral it could still happen people it
doesn't but it means it probably
shouldn't have been made in the first
place yeah definitely like that like how
you regret making it and and loads of
videos like that but I understand what I
was thinking at the time and I think a
lot of people who are making videos like
that do it because it it gets rewarded
online like like loads and loads of
people watched it they they followed it
it created it boosted our profiles
that's what it does
so I mean you you're you're obviously
young men and and clearly people's
political opinions people's you know
economic outlook all the rest of it that
all changes over time but how far away
are you would you say genuinely from
from the young man in that video massive
like I like I can I actually can't watch
that video or anything else like it in
terms of the arguments personally
completely disagree with that now
completely changed as a person and then
publicly like like just trying to get
sort of views or trying to grow your
profile for without any sort of strategy
or for no reason is completely unhelpful
as well especially if it's a if it's at
the expense of like an increase in hate
crimes in your country because you've
been flame tensions like it's not it's
not helpful so in every single way I
would have moved on from that to what
extent there was who was that that that
piece of work and other pieces of work
to what extent was that a reaction to
what what you saw as as a biased
mainstream media for you I mean you
mentioned there the internet allowed me
to do this the Internet was the one that
rewarded me the Internet was the one
that gave me the the opportunity you
know if you'd read a bit the mainstream
media at the time wouldn't you perhaps
about a different opinion
well like I do think there's advice and
in a lot of the traditional and
establishment media they they are really
reluctant to talk about certain issues
and that led to me going to fringe
alternative media and a lot of people
going to preach alternative media to
find their new sources and taking it
really seriously and a lot of the time
there's more fake news on the on the
right than there is on the left and that
can bring you down a rabbit hole which
makes everything much much worse and and
the way I was in that video is the way a
lot of people are which is pretty
hysterical when they spend too much time
online reading far-right websites where
they literally believe that we're at war
and that the enemy is within us and
there is crazy sjw's at every at every
turn and feminists and everyone's crazy
and there's a big battle going on and
that mindset is really really toxic like
it's probably why we've seen an increase
in in in hate crimes and in the growth
of the far-right terrorism threat in
Britain mi5 had just opened a new
department and I would say that the work
I did might have even contributed to
that being open so that so the work
which you'd probably concede would
incited hatred would have incited anger
at the very least and some people honor
on the basis of a false premise you're
not trying to justify that on the basis
of Scotland Yard perhaps took a little
bit more notice afterwards no I think
genuinely if I wouldn't have been
involved in a lot of this stuff that
that wouldn't have happened would you
concede that potentially possibly you
were a racist for at least part of your
life the racialization of Islam is
something I used to pass off quite a lot
but it does actually make sense and I
think yeah I think I could have been
described as as as that probably for a
while after after spending time on these
sites it happened so quickly
and you'd used you do start to demonize
people and you start to see things as
black and white
too much and yeah like you could a lot
of people in this movement fall into
that what's the reason for that peer
pressure what to do to behave in that
fashion that when you're surrounded by
people who are saying similar things to
you who are perhaps seeing them even
more bombastic when I'm thinking of
Tommy Robinson here when the people that
work the news sites that you're reading
or of a certain sense when the media
that you consume just in general is of a
certain type it's it's it's difficult
isn't it I don't think it's peer
pressure I think people think they're
right I thought I was right I think
Tommy thinks what convinced you you were
wrong there but well more time
researching and digging into it and
actually going beyond sort of headlines
and going beyond 4-minute YouTube videos
with Sam by it's explaining what you're
thinking because they the first initial
process the first sort of three or four
months to all this it was just watching
like rebel videos and things like that
there were like four or five minutes
long you can't become nuanced you can't
get into the actual art and you can
actually investigate
in four minutes or Orion headlines it's
going beyond that and actually traveling
and going to the world seeing that
things aren't like that isn't that then
the fundamental problem with the
alternative media to which you belong I
mean your evidence of this that actually
all you need is a a camera and an
internet connection and you can
broadcast stuff which even you conceit
was was just factually inaccurate and
probably insight it would have incited
some people you know if I want to get
story on the television you know I have
to do years of training years of working
in the backroom and then I've got to
persuade everyone else in the building
that this is a good idea you were able
to stick up something of which you were
embarrassed and which will now exist out
there in perpetuity isn't that
fundamental problem with the alternative
media I wouldn't say that's a problem
with the alternative media I think
that's a problem with people with bad
ideas who use the internet like that's
something a lot of them are fine with in
the alternative media well but you could
say they're saying about a lot of
mainstream media like the left say that
Fox News is a hard right extremist
organization they say that with a degree
of justification yeah well and a lot of
people say that at salon.com and the
Guardian is is a far left extremist
organization that endorses Antipa
violence so there's a lot of arguments
you can throw at different types of the
media establishment an alternative and
that like I understand a lot of those
arguments but it's about bad ideas and
good ideas not whether it's alternative
a mainstream plus alternative media
becomes mainstream you look at BuzzFeed
that started as like a catch sharing
website and now it's mainstream like it
does it it's all kind of it's all kind
of mixing into one kind of ecosystems
yeah it might have a good media and bad
Beauty but it's also about scale isn't
it and to suggest that the world there
are more people out there three
alternative forms of media pushing a
kind of a pro ante for at Proulx
violence narrative compared to those
like yourself in the past admittedly
pushing an anti-immigrant anti-muslim
like i mean there were lots more of you
who around than aware of the at the
salon times yeah but it doesn't mean
that it still comes down to the articles
and whether things are good ideas and
bad ideas like it always comes down to
that and and with establishment media
there's still massive problems within it
with with with the bureaucracy and
getting stories out like we broke a
massive story recently and we couldn't
get any mainstream media outlets to
publish it in the UK I want to talk
about that but first it for those who
don't know I mean how would you describe
Lauren southern because to be fair if
you're not friends with her if you're
not working with or the kind of the the
group thing the consensus appears to be
that she is at the very least all
by if not all right if not even
far-right what's your view of lon
I think our views have changed a lot in
the last insight since I've met her like
like myself this is why we have such a
close relationship because her views are
adjusting and moving we've traveled to
like 22 countries this year so far gone
to so many different cultures spoken to
so many different stories and that has
helped it massively like see the world
like like we do now in a much less
biased way I just think she's a Canadian
girl she's trying to find out the truth
genuinely about what's going on and
she's she's on a journey to to uncover
literally what's going on in Europe
what's going on in South Africa you
don't think that she perhaps suffers
from that which you suffered from in the
past that you've got a conclusion in
your head and you're going out there to
film stuff that lends weight to your
conclusion rather than what what
journalism is is going out there asking
questions and then and only then with
the basis of evidence
arriving at those conclusions I think I
can't speak for her but I'm I would say
maybe maybe years ago she used to be a
little bit like that but now it's just
gone through a total transformation just
like a lot of different people
loads of people have gone through that
process where they play they've either
left completely or completely more than
and shape their views and that's fairly
normal for someone who's 20 to 23 years
old but I'm just wondering whether or
not people can you know take it face
value or documentary produced by Lauren
southern who has made her views about
migration very clear and a documentary
made by you
who with Lorde and southern went to
Luton and handed out you know leaflets
that said ala is gay on them no you're
smoking there it was a little but it
also highlighted the issues in Luton I
mean if you if we went to a Christian
areand and said Jesus is gay no one
cared we were talking about censorship
and we're talking about blasphemy laws
and if you're gonna make a point isn't
that quite an infantile way in which to
do it worked although you're talking
about it on television it worked
otherwise it wouldn't otherwise no one
would be hearing about it no one would
be having that conversation sometimes
you have to do something a little
extreme a little bit out there so that
people can at least open a dialogue and
talk about it and it worked but did it
I'm not sure that you weren't speaking
to anyone other than them then converted
already but my point again is a simple
it is not enough for people who have had
as you say gone viral millions of hits
on their videos yourself and Lorne and
could it is not sufficient sometimes a
general walk I would
wrong back then that I'm right now I am
legit I'm entitled it is legitimate for
me to challenge everything that you say
on this topic given what you've
previously said on this topic sure like
I think age is a factor I think if I say
something I'm 30 years old and I'm a
well-rounded person then that it's
different to saying something when
you're like twenty one twenty two or
even 19 and you genuinely come out you
say I no longer believe that I no longer
endorse those views I do think there's a
difference between that and then someone
just saying oh well I don't really
believe it anymore so I would I would
argue against that does Islam um do
Muslims actually pose an existential
threat to Europe in your view I think no
no of course not the movement of people
globally on mass causes an existential
threat to nationalism and patriotism and
and sort of homogeny in a lot of
societies whether it's people from
Afghanistan to Syria or people from
Syria to the UK or people from the UK it
will always happen because cultures that
haven't been living together for tens of
thousands of years immediately crossing
over is gonna cause social tensions I
mean sorts what do we do well you would
have more controlled immigration like I
at like New Zealand maybe like Australia
maybe like Japan just more reasonable
immigration policies I mean you mean you
mentioned Australia there I mean would
you be happy with hundreds of people
sitting on a boat in the baking Sun off
the coast of you know the the Southie
off the coast of southern Europe in the
way in which the Australians have done
doesn't you be happy would you be
unhappy with you know people trying to
get your people trying to get into the
United Kingdom being sent off to an
island off the north coast I would be
happier with that than the hundreds of
people that are drowning the
Mediterranean Sea trying to get here
because we allowed the boats to come in
its acts as a deterrent it might be
uncomfortable for them but it acts as a
deterrent in Australia we basically have
no deaths no detention acts as a
deterrent you not just believe that it's
turning back the boats and not allowing
the boats to land on your shore acts as
a massive deterrent and will genuinely
save lives from people who were
constantly risking their lives to go
across the Med and hundreds of people
drowned every year all right six people
drowned while we were in lesbos and that
we that's disastrous we turn the boats
back detention disasters idea turn the
boats back and put them on the place
where they left which would be you know
turkey or not okay I mean I can't I
can't I can't work out whether you're
being provocative or just deliberately
naive here I mean do you honestly think
that if the boats were sent back to
North Africa
they'd all get off the boat and wander
home just say gentle walk you got his
guys fair enough we'll try we've tried
once we're gonna head home I think we
handed in to the police
regardless if they if they are not
allowed
to harbour the boats on shore then it
will act as a deterrent because
otherwise hundreds people are gonna be
gonna be training because we're we're
basically in cell device [ __ ]
the hundreds of people have been dying
hasn't acted as a deterrent no it
doesn't of people have died in the
Mediterranean and I'm still women with
newborn children are getting into those
boats I just don't see it because in
Australia it worked we're looking at
actual examples that work to prevent
loss of human life and it's worked
that's all that's all we can say about
it well it hasn't worked here it hasn't
done the ultimate determine the
ultimately no man is surely losing your
husband losing your children you know
dying in the Mediterranean a lonely cold
death yep and that hasn't worked as a
determine so I'm just saying it III
think your arguments a false one but it
worked in Australia so it but it's a
different thing you're arguing that
turning back boats in Australia is the
same as people dying in the shores here
they're completely different scenarios
so what it's a deterrent one is when
it's also a deterrent but one isn't much
stronger deter it which is to say no
we're not going to accept boats pulling
up we'll send you back to the
authorities and the countries that you
came home from and it will work at work
in Australia I just want to trying to
get delve a little bit deeper because I
have to admit I mean I find your
fascinating character by finding very
difficult to understand understand
entirely now where does your where does
your your sexuality feature and in all
of this because you are you are a gay
man you're out and but you're also of
the right wing and you have to concede
that the right has not necessarily been
a happy place for gay men for a long
time at least well I would say the
majority of homophobia that I've ever
witnessed in my life has been from the
Muslim community in East London where I
was there I've never really experienced
homophobia from the right in Britain
ever any right-wing circles the
Conservatives maybe a little bit in the
extreme far right but nothing compared
to to the Islamic homophobia so I would
say it's a little bit different to
difficult to argue against that but my
sexuality doesn't play anything into the
morals of what I'm talking about a lot
of gay people become right-wing become
far-right because they think that
there's a threat to their sexuality from
mass migration from Muslims I that's not
where my Arc was coming from I suppose I
suppose the point is that from from any
gay people and of course things change
but for many gay people for a long time
the left
felt almost like the natural home
because it was the left predominantly
that were pushing through some rather
uncomfortable
social changes and changes to
legislation I loved what the left did in
the 60s 70s and 80s with with the civil
rights movement with the rights for
women with the rights for gays it's it's
groundbreaking it's what made us as
Westerners great I always thought the
left was fabulous when I started at
university I was like of course I'd be
on the left of course everyone taught me
that and I seemed they were the ones who
are progressive caring you know that was
the best thing but it wasn't until I
actually saw what was going on until I
actually started seeing the the
homophobia from the people that they
were already friends with the army
anti-semitism that the left are willing
to put up with but I thought oh it's
losing their touch a little bit it never
used to be like that as well they're
losing their touch completely and they
need to start that out right now we're
here in central London where nearly a
million people have closed most of the
streets where they're having a massive
prides throughout this city and they've
all come together to protest one thing
and that thing is so we have just got
back from what I can only describe as
the city of Babylon where a million
people came together to just be
degenerates to completely destroy the
city and make a total mess of the place
to protest nothing that's what I think
about it and I think the whole thing is
just a complete disaster I don't see a
point in it what do you think well I
think it's funny that you're a gay man
and I seem to be more Pro gay than you
I've always enjoyed right when I've gone
along sir but so what is it you see as
as wrong not not just with pride but I
think there was there was a nod towards
a concern about gay culture more
generally as well in the UK well I just
I just think it's it's a massive waste
of police resources and it annoys a lot
of people I think it creates homophobia
to behave like that in front of children
to behave like that in the middle of the
street to to walk like dry humping in
the street taking off all your clothes
being pretty much naked like being super
Deportes in the middle of the street
like it's not a video Newcastle it Chuck
a great time have you well that's
tracking out time that's after children
that's after nighttime that's after the
watershed this is in the middle of the
day it's not great doesn't go off a
great image and it's and they're not
really fighting for anything this is
what's so annoying about the gay
community they've become so relaxed
they've become and they become engrossed
in this victimhood as well you know the
left-wing establishment the media have
told them that they're these massive
victims and they believe it for nothing
no that mean they have all the rights
they need I don't I don't really quite
understand what's going on there I think
a lot of gay people are sort of waking
up to that as well absolutely you don't
that you don't think that there are
still advances that the gay community
here in the United Kingdom
we even move outside our borders but
there are still changes that need to
happen there are zero changes of the gay
rights creation needs in this country
zero actually less because they have
privileges they have the the additional
hate crime laws which straight people
don't get they have they have privileges
in terms of prime like if you get
attacked in the street Ronda or someone
glasses you and you're in a straight
white guy and you call the police
they'll say okay this is not the you
know this is bad you know that maybe
come in half an hour and they'll deal
with it if you say it was a hate crime
if you happen to be gay they'll probably
be five police cars coming up they'll
investigate it until they're blue in the
face they'll keep and keep going that
creates a resentment as well within the
straight community against case which is
very very bad and also it's just
undeserved privileges so I would say
less you are clearly an intelligent
articulate sensitive you know young gay
man with something to say and then you
see it and I find myself kind of having
to bite my tongue you know you have you
had a genuinely good news story about my
great micro organizations and the way in
which they work which you know you
listen to Lauren southern she uses as an
argument against all migration you say
you wear a racist but you know I look at
what you're saying to me no and I'm not
sure I'm not sure that there are there
is a country mile between that angry
young man down in London Bridge and the
man sitting in front of me that I see a
radicalized angry young man sitting in
the sofa here the proof is always in the
pudding with this stuff like I haven't
done anything like that in literally a
year the stuff that we're doing now is
is in argue bullets it's investigating
journaling into into criminal activities
that that's it it's not it's not
screaming at Muslims it's not demonizing
people it's not it's not being racist
it's none of those things and that's not
a strategy that's genuinely the process
that I went through when I traveled the
world and realized that things were
completely out of hand I was believing
in a basement or wherever I was living
at the time like that that's literally
what was happening and the proof is in
the content that we're making like
that's not something we can argue with
but simply put if you could close
Europe's borders you would I think the
fact you have to think about that not
I'm trying to think of the right was the
right sort of way to put it I wouldn't
close the borders but I would say we
need more regulated controlled
immigration so the rest of the brightest
from all of the countries in the world
from you know if
someone wants to come from Pakistan and
they want to work for the NHS and they
want to add to the UK absolutely come
that would be amazing that something
that would add great value to our
country one of the things that has made
Britain great is is the fact that we are
a multicultural society but not the fact
that we're a massively multicultural
society where Britons are a minority and
that's not something we want to happen
but multiculturalism isn't bad in
moderation do you disagree with my
characterization of you as a young
radicalized man
I absolutely discrete that but I
understand why you'd say that that makes
sense and I'm sure I will see each other
again in a year and you'll think
differently given all the good stuff
that's coming out Killen Robertson
lovely to see you again thanks for
joining us thanks